well uh I hope you've all voted on the
resolution yes no or undecided the U.S
should have free immigration except for
those who pose a security threat or or
have a serious contagious disease
speaking for the affirmative Alex
narasta Alex please come to the stage
speaking for the negative Francis Menton
Francis please come to the stage
Alex you have uh 20 minutes to speak for
the affirmative uh you can take the
podium take it away Alex
well thank you to the Soho Forum Gene
Epstein Nicole Espy reason for
organizing this debate over whether the
U.S should have free immigration except
for those who pose a security threat or
have a serious contagious disease
it's fitting that we are having this
debate in New York city in the United
States the United States had free
immigration for the first 85 years after
Independence it continued with a policy
close to free immigration for an
additional 50 years
free immigration allowed tens of
millions of immigrants to arrive on
these shores without burdensome
regulations immigrants who contributed
mightily to the economic and social
development of the United States
but the current legal and immigration
system is essentially planned
soviet-style mass that restricts
immigration to a small fraction of what
it otherwise would be now I have a slide
that should go up at just this moment
right now if everything is well timed
there we go this is a very this is one
half of a very simple legal map of one
small part of the legal immigration
system can we have the next slide please
and here is the
other half of that map that's just one
small part of the legal immigration
system it is second in complexity only
to the income tax this is the reality of
American immigration law and policy
today
this is the reason why so many illegal
immigrants break immigration laws to
support the current laws or to support
even more restrictions is an endorsement
of this system or something similar to
it on the other hand free immigration is
a policy consistent with the principles
of Classical liberalism libertarianism
and the enlightenment let's start with
those principles
we have a presumption of individual
liberty people have inalienable and
individual rights immigration
restrictions require the government to
use violence and the threat of violence
to stop the voluntary movement of people
across borders this use of government
power restricts the inalienable rights
of Americans and those of immigrants
those who oppose free immigration should
have to show that government Force which
is funded coercively at taxpayer expense
should be used to stop the peaceful
voluntary and mutually beneficial
interactions of willing individuals the
presumption that starting point must be
free immigration and the government can
only restrict it if it has a very good
reason
an important way our debate is about
more than immigration there are really
just two broad political philosophies
the first is liberty and the second is
power
it is the exercise of power not Liberty
that requires justification and those
who Advocate coercion in any Arena must
bear a heavy burden of proof free
immigration is part of the philosophy of
Liberty it stands on its own it requires
no special justification immigration
restrictionism is the philosophy of
government power over the lives of
individuals and the use of government
power to stop immigration must be
justified and it must be justified well
to overcome the presumption of Liberty
in our debate today my opponent will try
to justify infringing on individual
liberty but all of his counter arguments
will be small and unconvincing compared
to the presumption of Liberty in short
the philosophy of Liberty will overcome
the philosophy of power
one of our individual inalienable rights
is freedom of Association which means
the freedom to voluntarily interact with
whomever we want on a mutually agreed
upon basis on that principle alone
Americans should be able to associate
with immigrants at any time they choose
assuming the Immigrant also chooses to
associate
this extends of course to hiring firing
marrying renting an apartment or any
other type of voluntary interaction
the state the government should not
interfere unless under exceptional
circumstances like a criminal conspiracy
to injure the life liberty or property
of others borders exist to limit the
powers of governments they do not exist
to limit the liberty of individuals
another core principle we hold is free
market capitalism an economic system of
decentralized voluntary economic
interactions with mobility of capital
entrepreneurship and labor the movement
of people toward Economic Opportunity is
an important component of capitalism and
every government regulation and law that
restricts that freedom imposes a burden
on Americans and on immigrants
these are deep and ancient traditions in
the western world that are infringed
upon by government immigration
restrictions
immigration restrictionists and my
opponent have much to overcome to
justify taking away our fundamental
inalienable rights by supporting
government control over immigration
they do not even come close to
overcoming it
moving from the realm of principle to
practicality the economic benefits of
immigration are extraordinary immigrants
make three to ten times more money in
the United States than in their home
countries even after adjusting for the
cost of living
Economist Michael Clemens has estimated
that free immigration would increase the
amount of global economic production you
know gross World product the global
version of GDP by 50 to 150 percent
that's 50 to 150 trillion dollars of
extra production every year in the
United States immigrants are already
responsible for a disproportionate share
of employment or twice as
entrepreneurial as native born Americans
create job opportunities for natives are
more likely to patent and are
responsible for much of the productivity
growth in the U.S since the end of World
War II there are no counter arguments
that will be made tonight that come
close to showing that the cost of
immigration are higher than those
benefits benefits of that under a global
system of free immigration would
increase annual economic production by a
present value a present value of about a
quadrillion dollars now I promise that's
a real number
I had to look it up it's a thousand
trillions take my word for it or Google
after the show but even if that estimate
is exaggerated by a factor of 10 we're
talking about a present value of a
hundred trillion dollars
in a purely consequentialist framework
immigration restriction is a Monumental
economic failure relatedly The Economic
Consequences of immigration are so large
and so positive that they can't even be
used to overwhelm our principles but
immigration restrictionists still have
many other arguments against immigration
on crime and Public Safety immigrants
are about half as likely to be
incarcerated as native born Americans
now it's true some groups of immigrants
by countries of origin have higher
incarceration rates others a lot lower
illegal immigrants Based on data from
Texas have a homicide conviction rate
that is either a touch higher in most
years or a touch lower in a couple other
years compared to native born Americans
you know depending on the year you look
at
since 1870 immigrants overall have a
lower incarceration rate than native
born Americans and specifically also a
lower incarceration rate than white
native born Americans the overwhelming
impact of immigrants on crime is small
and generally they lower the crime rate
in places where they move terrorism is
another threat there were 219
foreign-born terrorists responsible for
3046 murders in terrorist attacks on U.S
soil from 1975 through the end of 2022.
the chance of a person being murdered in
one of those attacks is about 1 in 4.3
million per year
98 of those deaths were on 9 11.
terrorism is a small and manageable
threat without more immigration
restrictions
immigrants also assimilate rapidly into
American culture according to research
by Jacob vigdor an economist at the
University of Washington
immigrants and their children assimilate
rapidly when they learn English language
education levels income Civic engagement
and religious attitudes the
grandchildren of immigrants are on
average
indistinguishable from native born
Americans whose ancestors have been here
for centuries when it comes to patriotic
sentiments immigrants Express slightly
more patriotism than native born
Americans when it comes to political
opinions immigrants have policy opinions
similar to natives but 10 devote more
democratic for the first generation
subsequent Generations are nearly
identical to long-settled Americans
immigrants do not take our jobs nor do
they lower our wages immigrants are
workers that's true so they increase the
supply of labor you might think that's
lower as wages and in some cases for
some workers that's probably true but in
most cases it's not true because
immigrants are also people and they buy
things and that increases demand
and immigrants who buy are people who
buy goods and services and that creates
other employment opportunities and
raises wages especially for native born
Americans every economic argument
against immigration is just normal
left-wing zero-sum economics applied to
people once you see that it's impossible
to take the economic argument for
immigration restrictions seriously
however
the welfare state complicates the
economics of immigration
Milton Friedman famously said quote you
cannot simultaneously have free
immigration and a welfare state unquote
many of you have probably heard that
quote before but whether you can have
free immigration and a welfare state
it's an empirical question you have to
look at the data it is not a matter of
principle if immigrants consume more in
welfare than they pay in taxes it would
be a problem
unfortunately Friedman didn't conduct
any Empirical research on this question
but those who have done this research
find that the empirical evidence doesn't
support Friedman's Point immigrants use
27 percent less welfare than native born
Americans on an average per capita basis
if we widen that analysis to include all
government expenditures education police
welfare military Etc and all taxes paid
by immigrants immigrants pay one dollar
and 43 cents in taxes for every dollar
they consume in government benefits and
that includes the state federal and
local levels
native born Americans on average and I'm
sorry to have to insult my fellow native
born Americans
pay only 73 cents in taxes for every
dollar they consume in government
benefits
paradoxically it may be impossible to
sustain a large government without the
massive boost and tax revenue and
economic growth delivered by immigrants
that last point of course uh does give
me mixed feelings as a committed
libertarian because I want to abolish
the welfare state but those are the
facts and I'm here to give them to you
now let's zoom in on education for a
moment an enormous government-controlled
sector of the economy
state and local governments Supply
taxpayer-funded education at a price of
zero to students the students include
legal immigrants illegal immigrants and
the U.S born children
it also of course includes the
grandchildren great-grandchildren and
the descendants of all past immigrants
public education is expensive with all
levels of government spending about
seventeen thousand dollars per pupil per
year on average across the country with
much higher costs in some locations than
in others
but immigrants do end up covering that
in tax payments if you think about it
for a moment
most economists model education as an
investment in human capital
that pays off and more productive and
educated workers who make higher wages
and higher wages mean more tax revenue
thus in education you know up to a point
don't get that master's degree in poetry
or anything like that but education up
to a point increases wages of educated
workers which increases their tax
payments another reason is that
immigrants tend to enter the U.S after
they are done with high school and start
paying taxes immediately
while their young children or U.S born
kids start consuming government
education a little later
thus you've got a taxed worker or
workers kids in public school and those
kids will eventually grow up start
working and paying more taxes because
they are more educated
now I want to make a principled meta
observation about self-described
Libertarians who are opposed to free
immigration
those of them who rely on the welfare
state to argue against free immigration
are not consistent Libertarians and
those who claim to be
anarcho-capitalists are contradicting
their own supposed ideology
they often argue like Milton Friedman
did in his quote above that because the
U.S has a welfare state then that means
the country can't have free immigration
or that we should even more radically
reduce legal immigration
that is a non-libertarian reaction to
the existence of the welfare state the
non-libertarian reaction is to use the
existence of welfare to oppose
immigration
the real libertarian reaction is to use
the welfare state to try to is to to the
welfare state is to try to abolish the
welfare state or at a very minimum
to build a higher wall around it
and no other policy issue do so many
self-described Libertarians use the
existence of welfare to argue against
individual liberty for instance
Libertarians want to legalize drugs I
want to legalize drugs but we have a
welfare state you can make the argument
quote the welfare state exists if drugs
are legalized someone somewhere well
overdose on drugs and go to the
emergency room that person could use
emergency Medicaid therefore we
shouldn't legalize drugs you never hear
a Libertarians make that argument
because it is obviously non-libertarian
another analogous argument we have a
public school system
do we ever hear Libertarians say Public
Schools exist if Americans are allowed
to have as many children as they want to
then some of those kids will go to
public schools and consume taxpayer
resources therefore every woman should
have to get government permission before
getting pregnant that's obviously
monstrous and non-libertarian the
libertarian response to public education
is to abolish or radically reform it not
to impose other restrictions on our
fundamental individual rights to reduce
the harm of other government policies
why do so many self-described
Libertarians suddenly develop a blind
spot to immigration that they don't have
on these other issues ludic Von mises
one of the most well-known Austrian
economists had some lessons here that
self-described libertarian opponents of
immigration should pay attention to
mises writings on interventionism which
is when the government regulates or
otherwise interferes in markets lays out
several problems but one major issue
with government intervention is that the
first intervention creates Problems by
disturbing the market process those
disturbances then lead to other
interventions in an attempt to correct
the problems created by the first
intervention and so on the cycle
continues until the entire economy is
controlled by government regulatory
regimes with bad consequences
libertarian immigration restrictionists
unintentionally fall into this bad cycle
of interventionism that leads to more
State control over the economy when they
endorse government rules to restrict
immigration and reaction to other
government rules in the market economy
those self-described Libertarians
opposed immigration because of public
education welfare or any other problems
created by anti-capitalist policy have
been LED astray the answer to immigrants
imposing some cost on public education
and the welfare state is not to get rid
of the immigrants it's to reform or
abolish welfare and public education
almost every problem that you want to
blame on immigrants is better understood
as a problem caused by bad public policy
elsewhere
do not fall for the supposedly a to the
answer of quote just close the border
unquote don't fall for the Temptation
that one violation of individual liberty
justifies another government
intervention that further decreases
Liberty keep your eye on the real source
of the problem the government
the reaction to immigration has severely
restricted the freedom of Americans
whenever any one of you wants to get a
job they must now fill out government
forms to prove that they are not an
illegal immigrant many states mostly
conservatives require that all new hires
including native born Americans must be
checked through a government database
Search tool called e-verify to ask for
permission to work to guarantee they are
not illegal immigration illegal
immigrants cooperation between local
federal law enforcement surveillance
building the wall goes on and on and on
Americans have to spend tens of
thousands of dollars to sponsor family
members or workers enough is enough
free immigration is part of the
philosophy of Liberty immigration
restriction is the philosophy of
government power it's time for
self-described Libertarians who are
skeptical of immigration to see that
shape up and to become consistent
Libertarians libertarianism isn't Buffet
stop acting like it
conservatives Libertarians classical
liberals and others support meritocracy
what are immigration restrictions but
the largest and most destructive system
of affirmative action for native born
Americans ever developed
as a believer in meritocracy and I know
my opponent is a believer in meritocracy
getting rid of immigration restrictions
like this will open up the United States
make us a much more meritocratic country
and destroy the last vestiges of
affirmative action that are far more
destructive than what the Supreme Court
recently struck down
the burden should not be on immigrants
or Americans to prove that they can
exercise their inherent rights the
burden should be on the government and
for restrictionists to show that these
government restrictions should be
imposed on free and willing people who
just want to interact with each other
voluntarily libertarian and classically
liberal values America Enlightenment
values are support for free market
capitalism and support for meritocracy
all compel us to support free
immigration thank you
[Applause]
Francis betting for the negative take it
away Francis
and thank you to Gene Epstein and thank
you to the Soho forum for having me to
this debate on I'm so happy to be able
to do one of these I once did a previous
Soho forum debate only one which was
virtual so this is my first time before
a live audience here at the Soho forum
and I'm I'm so pleased to do it now uh
why why me for this Soho forum debate
I'm not really a known guy in the
immigration uh
policy world I do have a Blog Manhattan
contrarian I think I'd certainly hope
that many of you or most of you are
readers if you're not you should be and
I've written on immigration from time to
time but the immigration policy world
is pretty much divided between people
like Mr norasti who takes a very
principled but
somewhat extreme position of wide open
immigration that's his position that's
the position of his employer the Cato
Institute and others on the other hand
there are think tanks that are very much
restrictionist and think immigration
should be greatly restricted if not
eliminated or at least there should be a
moratorium
um
so but this is a Libertarian debate
series and I'm I think one of the few
people who you could say is kind of in
the middle I support robust immigration
I believe strongly in the principle of
Freedom that and and uh Liberty that uh
Mr naroski was so eloquently supporting
I support robust immigration but that's
not the same as unlimited immigration so
uh the resolution here
I'll read it the U.S should have free
free immigration except for those who
pose a security threat or have a serious
contagious disease now that is really
quite an extreme proposition and I I
actually thank the Soho forum for
um for giving me a proposition like that
which shouldn't be terribly difficult to
defend
uh
um even those of us who are very much in
favor of robust immigration that the
totally free immigration idea uh really
is too much and I and I will
as much as I support the principles of
Freedom that Mr naroski talks about I
want to kind of break my the arguments
that I'm going to be making down into
two categories
one of them is that all the benefits of
immigration
that he talks about
are completely dependent
on the maintenance of our basically
libertarian system that we have in the
United States
that's what makes it all work and if we
can't maintain that
then it all falls apart
so
um
what do I mean by that well you might
not think we have such a basically
libertarian system
there are a lot of restrictions that he
was talking about that there aren't
libertarian at all but in this world our
system is pretty libertarian we have
private property we have free exchange
of property we have
we have free use of your labor yes there
are regulations and there are
restrictions but but basically our
constitution keeps the government from
undoing that we have a culture of
individualism of hard work
entrepreneurialism and self-reliance
that doesn't exist in a lot of the rest
of the world not only that but there is
a rather large political movement that
that
um we're all aware of
sometimes known as the left which is
fundamentally opposed to all of that and
wants to undo it
um
so
we might think that our system is hugely
robust and hugely
immune to being
undone and I submit to you that it is
not now let us let us take a look
at
what the rest of the world looks like
and what we would be facing in an
unlimited immigration world
first a few numbers the current U.S
population is about 330 million
current world population recently passed
8 billion so we are approximately four
percent of the world population 96
percent outside 24 out of 25 people in
the world live outside the United States
so just one in 24 of those people coming
here would mean doubling our population
two out of 24 means tripling our
population and the current population
becomes a small
minority
of who we have in the country
U.S per capita GDP is about seventy
thousand dollars
take the rest of the world take out the
U.S and and the rich countries Europe
Canada Australia a few petrol States
which are about 1 billion out of the
eight billion people and the other seven
billion have per capita GDP of about
seven thousand dollars and the majority
of them well less than that so
of course many many people would want to
come here is is it as many as our entire
population
not in a year I don't think so but it
could very well be in a short period of
time now
um
what happens
when large numbers of people like that
come
first of all
immigrants this is a little-known facts
immigrants get counted for Congressional
reapportionment
and and presidential voting
as soon as they arrive not when they not
when they get to vote not when they're
legal or illegal how many people here
knew
that illegal immigrants absolutely are
counted in the census for purposes of
congressional reabortionment and
presidential electors anybody here know
that
oh we got at least a couple of people
but that's a completely well established
completely well established proposition
and of course legal immigrants too not
just when they become citizens and can
vote
that is why the left wants a lot of
immigrants immediate immigrants they're
hoping they go into Democratic areas
so congressional districts
have different numbers of Voters because
some of them have a lot of immigrants
and some don't the district with the
fewest
voters of all congressional districts
they all have the same population but
the fewest voters is the Alexandria
ocasio-cortez District in Queens
and Bronx
it could bring in enough immigrants as
uh as they have population
they doubled the population with no more
voters and they get two congressmen
instead of one and the same thing could
play out across the country but more
more generally than that
and and the expectation of the left by
the way is that the immigrants would go
into the heavily Democratic areas and
swing the Congress very quickly but
beyond that how would the immigrants
vote would would the immigrants if we
had
not just a million immigrants a year
like we have now legal ones
and maybe a couple of illegals suppose
we had 10 million immigrants a year or
20. or 50.
which is not impossible
how would they vote well let's look at
how the Latin American voter votes
because that would be the
number one source
for a large increase in Immigration if
it were all opened up and if you look at
the Latin American voter you will find
that almost every country certainly
every major country
in Central and South America
has voted for an overt Marxist regime
within the past 20 years and most of
them within the past five
I mean I could give you one after
another Venezuela elected a Marxist in
1998.
hasn't been a remotely Fair election
since
the opposition leaders are jailed the
vote counts are highly dubious the
economy has been destroyed and the the
marxists keep themselves in power
forever Mexico
Mexico had
had a
what was a huge success story had a
a Election Commission that was known for
its fairness
and allowed center-right candidates to
be elected
after decades and Decades of one party
rule in the early 2000s and then in 2018
this guy amlo
over at Marxist got elected
immediately great increase in the
welfare state immediately a wave of
nationalizations of major industries and
he's gone after the election commission
and thrown out the people who oppose him
and he's rigging the election so that
his party will never lose again now the
Supreme Court of Mexico blocked him a
couple of months ago that's still up in
the air but that's what's going on in
Mexico how about Peru Peru
elected and overt Marxist in 2021
he immediately said he was going to rule
by decree huge crisis erupted he got
thrown out he got impeached and removed
from office at the end of 2022 but that
situation is not resolved the Supreme
Court has been backing
his opponents he's not in office right
now but he's very much claims the right
to it still out there how about Chile
Chile elected this Marxist borique in
2021 his big plank was to replace the
Constitution he immediately comes up
with a constitution that enshrines every
far-left dream like the right to welfare
the right to Health Care
constitutional rights for Animals I'm
not making that up
well the Constitution got voted down
boric is still in office and he's and
he's trying again I I won't go on too
long with this but the same story
Bolivia same story Colombia same story
Brazil same story Nicaragua Daniel
Ortega it's even worse Ecuador same
story one after another after another
this is what the Latin American voter
votes for so
all the economic benefits
that my friend is talking about
are completely dependent on our being
able to maintain a free market
capitalism non-mark non-marxist system
here
free market capitalism and non-marxists
are not the norm of the world
Latin America is poor because of years
and years and decades and centuries of
authoritarianism and non-libertarianism
that's what they vote for
unlimited immigration brings them all
here
if they're legal in the United States
they can vote if they first of all
they're counted for Congressional
appropriation apportionment immediately
they can apply for citizenship after
five years those are the rules
uh
I'll move on to a few other points let's
start let's talk about crime
um
I submit that Unlimited
with with unlimited immigration
increased crime is a very real concern
I'm certainly not saying that all
immigrants
are criminals
far from it
but in any given population the
criminals are a very small percentage
I am saying
that if you look at
the big population countries south of
the border which would be the immediate
source of a large increase in
Immigration if it were all opened up
they're all far higher crime rate
countries than ours and those are the
people who would be coming so
the
murder rate in the United States
and I will use that as a proxy for
overall crime rate because other crimes
are much more subjective and subject to
different definitions so murder is a
good proxy
I'll use the murder rate the overall
murder rate for the United States is
five per 100
000.
murder rate in Mexico 29 per 100
000. Venezuela 37 per hundred thousand
El Salvador 52 per 100 000. Brazil 27
Honduras 39.
Guatemala 22.
in other words
the main sources of a big influx of new
immigration
are places with crime rates five to ten
times hours
and I would submit to you that the raw
crime rate for the entire population
under understates the likely crime rates
of the Immigrant population why
because the immigration
population skews younger old people
don't commit many crimes younger do the
immigration population skews toward men
commit more crimes than women
not saying those are huge differences
but I think the crime rates I gave you
understate the prevalence in the percent
of the population that would become the
immigrants
now Mr norasti talked about a study he
did
for the Cato Institute in 2020 a big
study
it's well known and well reported and I
read it in preparation for this
which concluded that the
illegal immigrants have approximately
the same or lower crime rate than the
native born population
which it did
however I would point out and and he did
these studies I didn't but I also looked
up but there are counter studies and the
famous counter study which is a specific
study that addressed that one came out
in 2022 and it's by an immigration
restrictionist guy named camarota
from something called the director of
the center for immigration studies
but camarota says
Mr norasty's figures are all off first
of all it's only from Texas the reason
it's only from Texas is Texas is the
only state that actually breaks down its
crime statistics to break out
illegal immigrants but Camerota says
they don't know who the illegal
immigrants are
so
if they don't know
whether somebody is or is not they
record them as part of the general
population so a lot of crimes are
recorded as part of the general
population when they're not then over
time they find out more people were
illegal immigrants they changed the
statistics over time it turns out that
more of the crimes were committed by
illegal immigrants but they'll never
find out who all of them were and so the
study is
flawed in that respect now I
I can't say I know all the details all
I'm saying is there is
absolutely every reason to think that
the population
of
people who might
come in in an unrestricted immigration
regime would be skewed toward higher
crime rates and that is a
real concern another real concern is
competition for low-skilled work and
what I would submit is here
you can't
extrapolate
the results of how the low skilled
labor market has worked out
in a regime where immigration might be
10 or 20 or 40 million people a year in
the low-skilled category from a regime
where it's been one or two or three
million where it becomes suddenly 20 and
40 that is a very very different
situation
and the effect on the low skilled labor
market is highly likely to be very very
dramatic it would not particularly
affect me or anybody else in this room
but but it would be a dramatic effect on
the lowest
skilled and could drive their wages down
and that is a very legitimate concern
I finally want to talk about
culture
because culture
and economics is not entirely what this
is about it's also about culture
and
many of the people from around the world
who could come in without restriction
under this new regime
are people whose culture is very very
different from ours
those people outnumber Us by multiples
so how would we feel about accepting
tens and even hundreds of millions of
immigrants who
are intolerant of religions other than
their own
don't treat women as co-equals with men
demand that women be subservient to men
don't accept marriage outside their
religion
don't accept homosexuality
honor killings how about honor killings
these are serious issues now look at
what is happening in France France has a
large concentrated population of people
from one area
who have a very different culture from
theirs
they have come in
and and live in France they live uh
seething with resentment
a young
Muslim Arab man was recently killed by
police France erupted in riots for weeks
hundreds of police stations attacked
hundreds of schools thousands of
businesses burned down the interior
Ministry from France here is his quote
their goals are to destabilize our
Republican institutions and bring blood
and fire down on France these are
important issues
so
the success we've had with immigration
so far is with limited immigration where
we can assimilate those people we can
discuss
what a reasonable number of immigrants
should be maybe it should be increased
but unlimited that's a step too far so
thank you very much
uh five minutes every battle you can
take the podium if you'd like yeah
so he made several points in response
I'm going to go through them one by one
on the institutional point the idea that
these economic benefits will only arrive
if we maintain our free market system
he's absolutely correct on that when you
take a look at American history when
immigration was most restricted is when
the government grew the most we as I
said in my opening speech the U.S had
about free immigration for the first
hundred and thirty five years or so the
borders were closed in the late mid to
late 1920s right after that we got the
New Deal not too long after that we got
the Great Society programs in fact Paul
Krugman I don't say this very often but
he wrote an excellent column
called suffer little children and there
was about the immigration restrictions
of the 20s and how bad they were and you
said but if they never closed the Border
we never would have had the New Deal
because the best political argument
against welfare and a large state is all
these foreigners are going to come in
and take advantage of it and when you
remove that argument by closing the
Border you unleash the desires of the
median-american voter to have a lot of
stuff for free into tax to Rich
that's what happened in the New Deal
Vernon M Briggs Jr a socialist labor
Economist from Cornell who recently
passed away was very opposed to
immigration because he wanted the Great
Society program and he recognized that
without immigration
being four percent in 1965 four percent
of the population the lowest in American
history without that never would have
had a great society program
because the political arguments
in support opposed to welfare the
strongest ones are that immigrants are
going to come and take advantage of it
that's why the greatest surge in growth
and the size and power the federal
government happens when the borders are
closed when the borders are open growth
slows down substantially both since the
late 1960s and prior to the mid-1920s I
know it's hard to believe right now but
if the U.S government had been growing
at the rate it did when the borders were
closed the U.S government be
substantially larger than it is today
now why does that happen
um immigrants have policy opinions when
you ask them about policy Social
Security welfare taxes about the same as
native born Americans on all these
topics so that's like good and bad right
because native born Americans have
terrible opinions about these uh
policies but the reason that it cuts
down and kills the growth of government
is because immigrants kill labor unions
and labor unions are the number one most
effective Lobby
for bigger government and growth in
government and immigrants kill them by
undermining that
um another thing to record to recognize
is that immigrants are not a random
sample of people from their home
countries they are self-selected
um if immigrants were a random sample of
people from their countries I mean those
just aren't the people who move
um if you think that immigrants are
going to import their institutions I
think you've got to explain why Cubans
vote Republican uh Venezuelans built
Republican after fleeing socialism
Colombians overwhelmingly vote
Republican in the United States after
seeing what the farc did to their
countries the descendants of immigrants
from Eastern Europe from Taiwan from
Vietnam vote Republican because they see
what these things have done in their
home countries uh on crime
um the uh you're right about that study
the uh about the about the Texas study
uh the numbers that I gave were the
up-to-date ones which were about the
same a little bit lower a little bit
higher in some years for the illegal
immigrants in terms of culture what
cultural changes have happened in the
last 20 or 30 years that you that you
don't like
think of a few I can think of like
wokeness right that I don't like how
many of those were imported
how many of those are foreign
they were invented by native born
Americans for native born Americans when
you poll immigrants on things like
affirmative action you pull them on
things that are related to wealthness
that go back to the 70s far far less
woke than native born Americans when you
take a look at all the bad cultural
developments that have occurred at least
during my lifetime that I don't like not
a single one of them is imported but all
the good ones are like food you know
like uh I love that stuff
seriously what kind of Life Would it be
and about riots and France yeah riots in
France are terrible I right now employ a
French au pair to take care of my three
young children it is a political
tradition in France to Riot every two
years or so everywhere seems to me the
immigrants have assimilated well to
French political culture
on top of that
um
France does do some things bad you go
there you get welfare right away that's
not the rule in the United States but uh
you know a lot of these concerns that we
hear about I think they're vastly
overstated and we should be more and
optimist about this immigration has
worked great in the United States and
it's going to go with great in the
future and I think this wonderful Hall
full of people and everyone listening
out there who's an immigrant or the
descendant of immigrants uh proves that
thank you
but miss buddy would like to take the
podium well yeah yeah okay
well I think the the biggest piece that
Mr norasti is missing is the huge
numbers that are out there that could be
coming and the
affect the potential effect on stability
and and I guess related to that is the
really extreme nature of the proposition
he's trying to defend which he hasn't
really uh
grappled with so I I mentioned how huge
the numbers are that we only have one
person out of 25 in the world there's 24
out of 25 left to come with and all of
their uh incomes average less than a
tenth of ours so there's every reason to
think that large percentages of them
would want to come and in fact Mr
norasti emphasized that when when he was
pointing out that the the wages zero
three to ten times what they could earn
of course they'd want to come well
that's that's tens and hundreds of
millions of them not the one to three
million immigrants that we get today and
when he talked about how immigration
worked out in the unlimited phase
uh back before 1900 or up to about 1920
in this country it did when almost all
immigration was from Europe and the cost
of travel was Far Far higher than it is
today
lots of people
can get here lots and lots of people can
get here
let's just focus on one aspect
of the uh
of the extremeness of the resolution one
of the things in our immigration law is
that the immigration authorities are
supposed to assure themselves that the
person coming in is not going to be a
public charge that's the word in the
statute not going to be a public charge
and the person at least theoretically
has to prove that if they're applying
for legal immigration of course that's
one of the things that's gone by the
board with the wave of illegal
immigration but that is out there in the
statute
and
I think
most people even most open immigration
people would think that's that's a good
idea I mean can people it could it
really be
that somebody could say yeah my plan is
to come in and go on welfare and live on
that for the rest of my life that's the
plan well under this resolution
yes we have to take that person
not only that it's worse than that under
this resolution under this resolution a
a foreign government and it could be a
not very nice foreign government could
say this is our chance to get rid of all
the people we don't want I mean um maybe
the security aspect of the resolution
precludes
um
convicted criminals but how about
how about the Beggars the street people
the drug addicts how about we empty out
our asylums and put them on boats and
send them over to the United States this
resolution says yes the United States
should take those people
really
um again I I basically support the
uh
the libertarian principle but I think
that our government has some
responsibility to the existing citizens
and the taxpayers not to
burden them completely
unreasonably which that would do now
um
I think there there could be a fair
debate out there as I said early on I
support robust immigration and I'm
prepared to support immigration
substantially more than we have now the
current legal is about a million to a
million and a half we're getting about a
couple of million of illegal maybe more
than that now but still three four
million a year
and there could be a very reasonable
debate
on what a
reasonable number is
those charts about how complex the
system is well it doesn't have to be
that complex it doesn't have to be
nearly that complex although changing
the law is very difficult and government
is is always a mess but there could be a
very reasonable debate
on what the
uh on what the level of immigration
should be but completely unlimited I
submit to you uh is is really quite an
extreme proposition that that is
impossible to justify and it's a
in a world where all we Libertarians
would like to see the government smaller
one of the
core functions of the government is to
establish the borders and to protect us
as a country from Outsiders not there's
nothing fundamentally
uh wrong with that as a function of
government so thank you very much
[Applause]
thanks you both and we now go to the Q a
portion of the evening
I want to establish a moderate's
prerogative task a couple of questions
and also I invite you both to ask each
other a question whenever you'd like to
do so
my my mother's question would be first
directed at Alex uh Nebraska
I notice you haven't used the term open
borders
and I don't know my related question is
to what extent are you proposing open
borders but then more especially when uh
when buddy Menton mentions that there
could be hundreds of millions of people
who want to fly in here every day
doesn't that potentially bother you some
related question is are you in favor of
open borders and are you fearful uh do
you share buddy meant fear that couple
hundred million people could show up at
Kennedy Airport in the next few months
if we if you got your way
so I this is on correct I don't like the
term open borders because I do think
that the government has a legitimate
role in keeping out violent and property
offenders security threats people who
who are sick and have a high probability
of harming the life liberty and private
property of people who are here so I
think that's totally legitimate so I
don't like open borders because it sort
of applies implies like none of that so
I like the term free immigration because
that's sort of what I'm going for when
you look at the U.S Constitution there
is no enumerated power for Congress to
have General restrictions on immigration
it doesn't exist it was invented by an
activist Court during the Progressive
Era there's no power for that at all
enumerated for congress there's a power
over naturalization so but but looking
at you know what it is that government
can do in other enumerated powers that
have been listed by that were listed by
the founders I think protecting life for
Liberty and property from anybody uh is
there legitimate function in terms of
the numbers those are limited by the
extent of the market
you know people come and go based on job
opportunities based on the price of real
estate in the United States based on the
demand for their labor and the supply
for the labor in the United States if
you look at inside of the United States
for instance there are huge wage
differences between different regions of
the United States right wages are a lot
higher in New York City than they are a
small town Nebraska right but not
everybody from small town Nebraska
decides to move uh to New York City to
get those higher wages because the
market regulates that so yes I do think
there would be a lot more immigration
those numbers are regulated by supply
and demand the extent of the market and
I think it is uh not wise to trust the
government to try to demographically or
centrally plan the population of the
United States by tinkering with
immigration That's What markets are for
and that's what they do best
so the really concern is you're saying
that you don't expect uh 10 million
people to show up and and apply for
welfare uh the next day well in terms of
the welfare rules that are currently on
the books and I've been on the books for
a long time if you come here on a green
card you are borrowed from almost all
means tested welfare benefits for the
first five years that you were here in
the United States if you're on another
work visa you're also barred until
you've been lawfully present on a green
card you know there's like there's like
40 different types of visas in the
United States and a lot of restrictions
and I support those restrictions you
know I want to get rid of the welfare
state if we can't do that
we do have a pretty robust wall around
welfare benefits and I'm saying Build
That Wall higher that's one wall I want
to build higher so we can do that but
even when you take a look at welfare
consumption currently amongst immigrants
on a per capita basis it's 27 percent
lower than native born Americans uh is
and when you take a look at the dynamic
effects of the taxes paid and the
benefits received Etc
immigrants reduce the budget deficit in
the United States
uh buddy do you want to comment on
Alex's answer to that question
yes no okay
all right uh all right we'll uh we'll
leave it open to questions so please
just ask your question ask a question
and no need to identify yourself uh do I
get to ask a question excuse me I
thought you said I got to ask a question
uh a question for you you're gonna say
I was going to save it for later okay is
that right okay yeah
good
I'm just thinking about migration uh
within the United States you have a
number of people moving to Florida
you have a number of people who went to
San Francisco so my question is like to
both you is if if we did have this free
immigration uh do you see us ending up
like Florida or like San Francisco well
Florida San Francisco what's your
favorite politics what well it seems
that Florida is doing well and San
Francisco is not and they both seem to
have I guess what we call free
immigration right within the United
States so
do you see free immigration the United
States becoming more like Florida
you know I guess the logical question is
more for Alex good going yeah go ahead
Alex so uh one of the phenomenons we've
noticed is sort of this self-sorting
where left-wing Americans like to move
to more left-wing places and right-wing
Americans move to more right-wing places
so you can see this in Texas actually if
only native born people who lived in
Texas voted it would be a democratic
state
but native born Americans moving from
other parts of the United States to
Texas people like my brother who are
right-wingers
are the ones who are keeping that state
fairly uh Republican and you see that in
places like Florida as well San
Francisco you know attracts more
left-wing Americans they're there so
there's a self sort of sorting that's
going on on this but one of the things
we have noticed is places like Florida
have gods and substantially more
conservative and they're voting over the
last several years
while the number of Venezuelans of
Cubans of nicaraguans of people from
outside of the United States who have
been fleeing failed socialist regimes
and Central and I mean failed socialists
is redundant right but you know failed
socialist regimes in Central and South
America uh have been moving there in
large numbers and voting for folks like
uh Governor
um Governor DeSantis
coming from you uh buddy yeah
uh no that's not that okay yeah buddy
the whole doesn't yeah I didn't want to
feel you uh I didn't want you to be
scanted so I will lay my question on you
buddy um a lot of the the initial as you
know preparation uh uh uh on part of
Alex to set the stage for his argument
was the default position the burden of
proof position uh namely that uh that
Libertarians support for the association
and if I may comment further uh you are
certainly right and I think Alex would
have to concede that um oh that we are
looking at unknowns in the future we
can't we have the past it it helps
predict the future but obviously it is
not sufficient to predict the future but
do you recognize uh acknowledge Alex's
argument that because the default
position is in favor of free association
that the burden of proof is on you to
demonstrate harm from immigration and
not on him do you recognize that
argument on his part I I don't know I
mean the term burden to proof I I was a
trial lawyer for my career and the term
burden of proof is a very specific the
default position
the burden of proof is a very specific
thing
here it's not such a specific thing I
would throw out the term default that
the default position is in favor of
supporting free association between
foreigners and U.S residents the default
position okay I I start from that
position too but when you have out there
seven billion people
uh in the world with an average income
of five thousand to seven thousand
dollars
uh per year each and they could make it
70. uh by coming here
and we only have a whole country of 300
million people I mean this is this is
what you call getting swamped and
and
the the prospect of actually maintaining
our constitutional system and our basic
libertarian approach to the world under
a constant assault from the left who
hates it
uh let alone numbers of immigrants that
could be a multiple of the people
already in the country that's a very
very daunting Prospect and
um uh I think that's enough to shift the
burden to proof comment on the on the
answer so what's interesting is the
General Social Survey it's the largest
biennial survey in the United States you
can separate by immigrants natives Etc
they ask a wide range of questions about
what you think about America is it the
best country in the world what do you
think about our institutions trust in
the government trust in the Supreme
Court Trust in the Constitution and
immigrants are far higher than native
born Americans in terms of trust and all
these things they think the Supreme
Court is pretty good they think Congress
you know
the Constitution pretty good they're
more patriotic than native born
Americans when you ask them on this
question I think if you're more you know
we get a self-selection effect where
people who like these things are more
likely to come here and you know the
cynical joke is all they haven't had a
much experience you know in watching
Congress to learn how to hate it but in
this sense of like if you're were if
you're worried about trying to preserve
the Constitution and these principles
um you know immigrants are I wouldn't
say the ones holding it together but
they are certainly more positive about
it than native born Americans are
because they have experience with things
a lot worse they really do and in terms
of like the burden of proof
there's this concept called the
precautionary principle that
left-wingers use all the time whenever
there's a new invention or a new
technology we hear an environmentalism
it is on the burden of the inventor to
show that this new technology won't have
some catastrophic effect on the
environment it's basically the way of
thinking that killed nuclear power
around the world you know the inventor
has to prove it so I'm glad they didn't
have the precautionary principle when
electricity was invented because we'd
still be using candles and I'm glad that
we didn't have to use the precautionary
principle in 1800 to justify the system
of free immigration that we had then
because if we had this system or
near-closed borders beginning in 1800 to
today there would be about 90 million
Americans and we'd probably all be
speaking German and I think things have
turned out pretty well it's the burden
of proof I think is on those who want to
use taxpayer money and the power of the
government to coerce and tell the rest
of us what to do to show that their
ideas are really good and it makes sense
next question
my question is to Francis
and my question is to Francis and then I
want to ask based on the data you
brought about violence and crime I'd
like to know if you would limit domestic
migration from the most violent states
in the U.S to the most proper states in
the U.S given that they have the same
diversity that we have internationally
many of these states they have other
cultures other religions they have
different races so I would like to know
if you would prevent domestic migration
from the most violent states to the last
violent States
did you get the question the answer is
no but you know I was I'm standing up
for the maintenance of our
constitutional system and uh although
this may be one of those things that you
can't find in the actual text of the
Constitution but the Supreme Court has
definitely held
that domestic
travel in the United States cannot be
restricted or prevented by any of the
states or the federal government so that
so that is uh that's wide open and I do
not propose
changing that coming from you Alex yeah
uh I wouldn't stop immigration between
states either
you guys agree on something for once
okay uh next question
so Alex you said earlier that Alex you
gotta go uh 27 of immigrants well
immigrants use welfare at a rate 27 less
than native borns
but you didn't mention uh that that
number is a heterogeneous mixture of
high-skilled middle-skilled low-skilled
immigrants immigrants from different
countries as Stephen Camerota of the
center of immigration studies has
pointed out in his studies which uh
Francis mentioned one of them
if you actually break that data down the
low-skilled immigrants including illegal
immigrants actually do use substantial
amounts of government benefits including
food stamps Medicaid uh they get tax
credits it's quite substantial
and so I would imagine that if you did
allow a billion people to come into the
United States within like five or ten
years you would get a massive rise in
whatever those you know existing welfare
usage rates uh usages are even at like
the same rate and yeah the Democratic
party is going to do everything they
possibly can to
enable that expand that and so it just
doesn't seem plausible to me that it's
going to be actually easier in a
situation like that to build a wall
around the welfare state let alone
abolish it
so uh two points on that about the other
study you mentioned by Stephen what he
does is I look at individual use which
allows me to tease out the immigrants
from The non-immigrants Steve looks at
households so in a household if you have
an immigrant and natives he counts all
of that in the household as being the
immigrants even those a bunch of natives
one of the other things Steve does is he
excludes two-thirds of welfare programs
from his analysis he excludes Social
Security and Medicare which are the
bedrocks of the welfare state in the
United States the largest portions of
the welfare state they are progressive
redistribution schemes that are means
tested in the sense that they give more
benefits to poor people than they do to
rich people they are the ones that are
actually bankrupting uh the United
States currently and when you do either
one of those differences you can exclude
the entitlements and discount the
immigrants or keep the entitlements in
and count the uh households the way he
does does uh it works out much closer to
my finding than it does to his uh
finding in there but if you want to read
a study at Steve Camerota Center for
immigration studies see how he counts a
bunch of native born Americans who use
welfare and blames on immigrants let me
just uh put a final point in the
president's question that that if you
take the poor immigrants rather the less
skilled immigrants that they tend to the
numbers which they use welfare much more
than they contribute you don't
acknowledge that fact so uh in our
fiscal cost analysis that we did about
um the uh the United States uh the
lowest uh decile of immigrants by
education do consume more in Government
Services of all kinds and they do pay in
taxes
um so that is true there are of course
some individuals who are in that drain
it's not like every immigrant right is a
huge net taxpayer right so the for the
lowest decile that's true so
um but when you compare to the lowest
American decile on that
um you know if immigrants if native born
Americans behave like those lowest
decile
um uh immigrants on there would be
substantially better immigrants do
behave substantially better than
similarly poor Americans on all those
metrics but you know it's right the
lowest decile uh do consume more in
benefits than they pay in taxes that's
true uh yeah well you comment buddy yeah
my comment would be that I don't think
it's legit to extrapolate what uh to
extrapolate from our current immigration
mix which consists of a million to a
million and a half legal a year many of
which are specifically selected for high
skills
and another million or two or three we
don't know how many of illegal in a year
but that mix to extrapolate from that to
what might be 20 or 50 or even a hundred
million immigrants many of whom could be
very very low-income people so I I don't
think to extrapolate from the numbers
that Mr norasti is giving Which is our
current immigration mix through the
prospective mix in this free immigration
system uh is is something that you could
really expect to happen
uh next question
so for the negative of the resolution to
win the only thing that needs to be
proved is that some immigrants who are
not security threats or have serious
contagious illnesses should be excluded
so my question to both of you is don't
you think that immigrants who would be a
net fiscal burden to the United States
which would probably be most of the
world population should not be allowed
to come to the United States if on you
know obviously you can argue that well
we can build a wall around the welfare
state but the reality is that I don't
think that Social Security and Medicare
the biggest fiscal problems of our
country are going to go so working under
those constraints don't you think that
some people who would be net burden
should be excluded
um I guess this question is directly to
you Alex could take it yeah so what
what's fascinating is the Social
Security Administration models increases
of immigration how it affects Social
Security and medicare's finances and
it's one of and it's incredibly positive
in terms of expanding the life of those
systems so what's interesting is and
they only model a slight difference they
only model like 250 000 more people a
year and how that extends a life of the
system by a couple more years but when
you model in substantial increases in uh
immigration let's say going from like 1
million a year to five or ten million
you can extend the life of the system
even without other reforms by many many
more years so it may be I think the
opposite of what Milton Friedman has
said right Melanie Friedman said you
can't have free immigration in a welfare
estate it's probably likely that you
can't sustain the current mix of
entitlements and Welfare without more
immigration immigrants who tend to be
younger working more likely to work and
the education mix has been going up
quite a bit for immigrants over the last
15 years without any legal changes uh
the the average education level of
immigrants has gone up by almost two
years over the last decade so much more
productive people so in terms of
sustaining and paying for a lot of these
programs I want to reform them and get
rid of them but it could be that having
more immigration the evidence I think is
pretty consistent with the fiscal
analyzes of this that having more
immigration allows us more wiggle room
to have more of these types of reforms
without you know cutting Grandma out of
Social Security too quickly I mean I
want to cut Grandma out but um you know
we can do it a little softer
uh sorry I'm not going to try to take on
the gigantic issues of Medicare and and
Social Security but I I do want to point
out that to win this debate all I have
to really win on is is that if if a
foreign government says we're going to
round up all our Beggars all are
mentally ill all our drug users and send
them to the United States
uh we shouldn't have to take them
um I have to say that is a very good
question and challenge buddy so if I
make excise moderators prerogative I
want to phrase it as a question to Alex
what if that happens some foreign
government says actually you know Cuba
is supposedly Center so that criminals
historically that happened although we
all saw Scarface we've all seen the
movie scarf well actually Miami seemed
to do pretty well as a result put that
aside what about Buddy's challenge uh
you know Iran says we're going to send
all these yo-yos to uh to your Shores
what are you going to do Alex well I
think a lot of that's covered in the
security threat portion of the question
a lot of it is covered in the serious
contagious diseases portion of that
right I mean a bunch of uh people who
are in prison or insane asylums in other
countries I don't know do you think
insane people insane asylums aren't
security threats
I mean if you want to take the widest
expansive definition of security threat
in serious contagious disease I wouldn't
argue with that we're arguing about a
fraction of a percent of people but
yeah I I think in the U.S population the
the people the the people who are not
criminals
but are somehow badly impaired by mental
illness drug use
[Music]
and the like is not
some fraction of one percent I'm not
saying it's half but it's more like five
to ten percent it's it's a it's a pretty
significant uh it's a pretty significant
number I I will say that one of the
things that I was thinking of using in
this debate was the Mario Boat Lift I
but I can't remember what year that
happened but 1980. 1980 yeah it's that
long ago holy cow but so I didn't think
everybody here would know about that but
that was a time when uh Castro people
started coming by both of the United
States and big numbers and Castro opened
up his prisons and said I sent huge
numbers of prisoners to the United
States but I I didn't think that was
fair because fairly speaking uh that
would be under the security risk
category I thought was it even such a
disaster anyway when they came yeah some
of it I mean some of them definitely
were right I think would be under the
security of this category but what's
interesting is there was a large robust
empirical literature and the
microeconomics
journals about the Marielle Boat Lift
because it increased Miami's population
by seven percent in 42 days
so it's a great one economy we like to
call a quasi-natural experiment
something that happened outside Miami
didn't cause it what happened to the
economy of uh Miami uh thereafter uh
what we basically saw using more updated
research by people like Michael Clemens
and Jennifer hunt who are two well-known
economists on this uh you may have gone
a slight wage dip for about a year or
two and then wages went right back up in
the trend you saw Miami creating more
jobs and more wage growth about 10 years
later than other comparable cities if
you owned real estate in Miami that was
awesome because all of a sudden you had
a bunch of people who had to rent
apartments and buy houses and native
born Americans owned the vast majority
of real estate I mean there were some
issues you know it wasn't perfect there
were there were some crime issues caused
by that I think sub-population that we
saw so dramatically depicted in the
movie Scarface great movie uh Al Pacino
fantastic somebody said I looked like
him in high school
they're probably trying to get on my
good side
you still do look like them yeah oh
thank you very much uh thanks mang uh
and so
um you know there is some cost to this
right I mean there's cost to a growing
city a cost or a growing country would
you rather have the cost of a growing
place or the cost of a shrinking place
would you rather be Houston Texas or
Detroit
next question
uh yeah I had a question specifically
for Mr Menton when you're distinguishing
the old era of free immigration in this
new proposed one you mentioned the
differences between mainly like the
European immigration and the southern
American Immigration however your
concerns with you know the uh you know
radical uh religious was also a concern
that was applied mainly towards the uh
Catholic uh Irish and Italian immigrants
and they didn't you know turn us you
know loyal to the pope yet so I was
wondering if uh you you think that still
is a differential factor between the two
well I think I think I understand the
question for the rest of us
I had trouble understanding you had
trouble understanding well I think he's
asking me to to to distinguish between
how the Catholic uh Italian and Irish
immigration of the late 1800s and early
1900s seemed to work out pretty well for
the United States uh versus what I was
uh raising of culturally very different
people who could come here in very large
numbers
uh today
from
very different cultures and potentially
destabilize our society in various ways
that I talked about have I got the right
idea I guess so
um and and the the numbers of Italian
and Irish immigrants uh were not small
but they were always and I don't have I
don't have percentages year by year and
I think there were times when the when
the immigration
wave of the time got over and Alex
probably knows better than I do got over
a million people when the population of
the country was under 100 million but
but today we get three and four million
when the population of the country is
between three and four hundred million
so it's not all that different the the
issue uh is I mean I might as well be
upfront about it the culturally
different people who are culturally
different in in ways that I think most
Americans would not find acceptable if
they were here here in the in the range
of 100 million people are basically
Muslims they're people who do not do not
recognize equal rights of women do not
recognize homosexuality they're not
recognize marriage outside the religion
etc etc now when we have
something like five or six million
Muslims in the country that's not a
problem but if it was a hundred million
that could be a huge problem and it's a
big problem in France where where the
number of North African immigrants
living in the country is about five
percent of the population it's not
really that High may I do this I see uh
three more people we're running out of
time I'm so what I'd like to do is the
three people who have a question could
you ask the questions and then maybe our
Debaters will be able to address those
answers in their summaries so please ask
your question sir uh go ahead what's
your question my question is for Mr
Menton which is that he talks a lot
about the dangers of immigrants from
countries with the Socialist values
influencing American politics
but uh as Alex I'm sorry I forget your
last name uh as he noted Vietnamese
Americans Venezuelan Americans Cuban
Americans all Trend Republican which is
one of the reasons why Republican why
Florida is going right
and then there's also the matter of
America's Constitution the fact that our
federal Judiciary is discovering its
backbone again
and then there's also the matter that we
have a really good job of implementing
socialist policies without outside help
what is the danger necessarily of
immigrants coming to the United States
with the apparent danger of influencing
political institutions yeah okay uh next
question uh that you may want to just
use somebody go ahead sir yeah my
question is actually for the pro which
is that I think like estimates say that
about 160 million people with our
current regulations want to migrate to
America so just using that number uh it
would be
so in America right now I think you know
is like in a housing crisis if you look
at California with 170 000 people who
are homeless uh and it hasn't really
been getting fixed with billions in
investment or whatever so my question
would just generally be how can these
hundreds of millions of migrants be
productive when they first need to like
be given housing and
uh how can we expect them to even find
housing if we can't find enough housing
for our existing population already okay
next and then final question so uh
this is a little bit similar to Mr
Mark's question the uh into the Mac
please so I just wanted to ask
um when it comes to this for the
negative when it comes to your kind of
analysis of how socialism and I guess
like Marxism is more present in like
South America and we kind of look at the
threat of immigrants coming over and
presenting that you know to the
government into American politics
to think of like the average immigrant
who's coming here a person who we can
understand that wants to come to a
country with a better per capita GDP a
country with better opportunities
do you truly believe that a person like
that would pose such a threat to
introducing Marxist like ideologies into
American politics on such a widespread
scale okay those that would be the final
question of the evening and uh we uh
have no more time for questions both
Debaters will be attending our after
party you can chat with them there
they're both obviously very approachable
but we want to go to the summary portion
of the evening uh the affirmative goes
first on summary Alex if you'd like to
take Napoleon please do so
the most robust counter argument that we
heard this evening is the one about
American institutions values capitalism
it's true immigrants come from countries
that have worse Economic Institutions
that have more socialism more
redistribution other problems with their
governments
however the person coming to the United
States is not a random person plucked
from those countries
from orbit and drop down the United
States it's self-selected the person who
is going to take a boat from Cuba is not
the hardcore committed communist who
loves Fidel Castro and thinks the global
Revolution is yada yada yada and all
that crap right it's people who don't
like what's going on in Cuba and want to
get out same for Venezuela same for
Nicaragua same for Colombia when you
poll take take a look at the opinions of
a lot of Mexican Americans of Muslim
Americans for instance when you pull
Muslim Americans and the people who are
over here from that part of the world
substantially more liberal on all of
these measures uh than the people in
their home countries they basically look
like Americans around the year 2009 in
terms of their opinion so like you know
13 14 15 years behind you know if you
think the current cultural values are
really good and people should assimilate
to them but they're you know they're a
little it behind not too far off when
you take a look at
measures of political opinions in the
General Social Survey immigrants
opinions are within the margin of error
of native born Americans on all of these
measures there's one big difference one
or there's two huge differences pretty
much
one that's relevant here is on the issue
of immigration surprisingly immigrants
like immigration more
um that's one of the reasons why in my
home state I'm from California
originally prior to prop 187 which was a
proposition voted on in 1994 pushed by
conservatives in the State uh it was
sold as an illegal immigration but also
um well not not too artfully sold as a
way to cut welfare for illegal
immigrants it also had a provision that
said if a Public Employee a government
employee comes into contact with any
illegal immigrant they have to report
that illegal immigrant to the ins
including kids in school anyway prior to
this proposition being voted on 1994 on
state level elections and California has
elections and off years on state level
elections Hispanics in the state split
evenly between Republicans and Democrats
and in some years a point or two more
for Republicans since then it's been
about 70 30
Hispanics for Democrats over Republicans
and part of the reason for that is is
the way that this message was brought
the political campaigns at the time is
if it was a very broad stroke broad
brush anti-immigrant message across the
board that were sold to States so the
danger I think is less from immigrants
coming in and voting and more from how
conservatives in the Republican Party
react to them and whether they decide to
make them the enemy now what's
remarkable is given all of what we've
heard from a lot of our friends on the
political right over the last several
years immigrants are trending a little
and Hispanics and Asians are trending
more to the right than they were in
previous uh decades uh Hispanic votes in
the last election if you take a look at
the exit polls about 39 percent for
Republicans which is way up from what it
was just uh 10 or 15 years ago and if it
wasn't for the end influence of Asian
Americans and leading the charge and
trying to kill affirmative action in
higher education through the S you know
students for fair admissions students
who were the ones discriminated against
most brutally by affirmative action in
public institutions leading the charge
and being such sympathetic victims I
don't think that we would have gotten
this overturning of affirmative action
for that reason so if you're really
happy about these political Trends I
think you should go out there and say
that these are the consequences of
immigrants and their descendants in the
United States lastly about meritocracy I
am a firm and Ardent proponent of
meritocracy the United States has about
4.6 percent of the world's population
you can't really call yourself a
meritocracy if you're basically closed
off from the rest of the world if you
say basically 95 and a half percent of
people can't even compete if they want
to so I I Claude the ending of
affirmative action University admissions
we have a lot further to go to end it in
Government Contracting in the private
sector and everywhere else but the
biggest place where we can break it down
is to remove the affirmative action for
native born Americans who don't need it
by the way uh I think we do quite fine
without it
um in the United States uh and to go
that that far basically my my base
principles of meritocracy pushed me in
this direction American history pushed
me in this direction and my principles
as a committed free market libertarian
pushed me in this direction to
supporting free immigration so thank you
very much
flat management battle buddy yeah
I guess I think the most important point
I could make in response to those last
couple of questions and also to what Mr
norasti just said
is that I I don't think it's fair to try
to extrapolate what a wide open
immigration system would look like and
how the immigrants who would come in
under that system in the aggregate would
shake out
uh from our current immigration system
or the statistics that have been
collected now there's
there's some important numbers that I
actually had in my notes here but never
got to in my prior presentation but I'll
mention now
So currently there as as everybody here
probably knows there's a huge surge of
illegal immigration across the southern
border going on but that's only the past
couple of years
before that
uh there was quite a bit of illegal
immigration but the fact is that most of
the immigration was legal and if you if
you go back
to
2019-2020 where I looked up numbers the
the number of immigrants living in the
country was about 40 million uh out of a
population of 300 and something million
so say 13 14 percent and of the 40
million roughly 20 million it breaks
down roughly 20 million citizens so
they've lived here long enough to apply
for citizenship and become a citizen 10
million legal and 10 million illegal
and of course the illegal has no route
to citizenship so that basically 30 out
of the 40 million
had come in Legally and the legal
immigration system as oh all kinds of
complications which you couldn't even
read and I don't even know what they are
but I I do know that in there there are
preferential things there are special
visas when a company wants somebody for
a special skill there's a lot of high
skilled people and they're they're also
people who come in by lotteries but the
legal immigration population is in
general a pretty high-end uh population
the illegal immigration less so well
what what's occurred now
is we've had a surge of illegal
immigration so several million nobody
knows exactly how many three four five
million over the past couple of years
may be more but those people nobody's
got statistics very much on them yet so
when you get statistics like Mr norasti
has he comes from a world where three
quarters of those people were the
high-end
legal kind now we're talking about a
world where there are going to be tens
and twenties of millions of people a
year who would not have won
the legal immigration thing and there's
every reason to think that they would be
preferentially a much lower
income
uh bunch and and
um also
come from all kinds of more troubled
places we don't know exactly but that
that is not a an illegitimate concern
and
and I don't really think you can
extrapolate from the the pre-existing
numbers so we are fortunate that the
South Americans are mostly of a religion
that's similar to ours France is not so
fortunate but I think that France does
illustrate for us the the risks of
having
uh cultural people very different from
us let alone we have a left in this
country and all over the world that
hates America that hates capitalism that
hates freedom and that is beating up
on uh everybody
in the world who is not a wealthy
American that you are oppressed that you
are a victim uh and and that Marxism and
socialism provide the root out of it for
you
uh and and that is something that's not
going away uh so
this is it would be a gigantic leap of
faith to suddenly have be taken in a
much much larger immigrant population
that could be a multiple of what we've
been having mostly lower income with a
whole education system and a whole left
ready to indoctrinate themselves that
their victims and oppressed
uh and and think that that's not going
to have a major effect on our political
and economic system here so
uh with that I think my time's about up
so I I will rest thank you
okay Jane please open the final voting
uh yes no or undecided the U.S should
have free immigration except for those
who pose a security threat or have a
serious contagious disease yes no or
undecided on the resolution and while
you're deliberating again I want to
invite you all to the after party two
blocks of town follow me uh follow buddy
Menton uh I think Alex and roster knows
where it is as well some others it's on
great Jones Street 55 great Jones Street
second floor we want to see you all to
discuss this issue as well as many
related issues as well I want to mention
that the soil form is back from
Porcupine Festival where we did a couple
of debates and one of them has has been
posted on YouTube and podcast and that
was a debate I did with David Friedman
illustrious son of Milton Friedman on
specific issues of libertarianism I also
appeared on the Tom Woods show to
discuss that debate if you go on our
website you'll find that debate in
particular between me and David and
going to Tom Woods show you'll find my
discussion of that debate we also had
another debate at pork fest between Matt
Kibby and Jeremy Kaufman on particular
issues of libertarianism as well and
that will be posted within about a week
but also right here on this stage on
August 21st of course both you guys were
invited to attend we will have Corey
DeAngelis who has made a bit of a name
for himself as Mr to school's choice I
believe he wasn't Cato but then went on
to bigger and better things and he will
be
I think we have the makings of a debate
I mean uh the uh he went on to other
things and uh he uh he will be debating
uh the issue of school choice against
Stefan kinsella and the specific
resolution is one of great contention
among Libertarians uh Corey will be
defending the resolution today's school
choice movement in the U.S is worthy of
support by Libertarians Stephen kinsella
will take the negative on that
resolution that's August 21st here at
the sheen Center and tickets are on sale
for that debate as well
September 18th we're going to have
that's going to be a Monday we're going
to have a sort of a knockdown track of
debate drag down debate between two
illustrious names yaren Brooke versus
Brian Kaplan uh yaren will defend the
rather aggressively worded resolution
annico capitalism would definitely be a
complete disaster for Humanity and that
will be defended by yaren Brook and of
course all our debates are civil I make
sure of that you guys were civil to each
other and even though the wording is
aggressive it will be a civil debate
Brian Kaplan uh will take the negative
that's a September 18th I'm sure you
guys want to come to both of those
events don't want to miss it uh October
18th we will have that will be Wednesday
October 18th we will have a debate
between Mark Mills and Rosario fortuno
uh Mark Mills will be defending the
resolution
uh between now and 2035
electric vehicles in the consumer Market
will likely disappoint environmentalists
by remaining a product bought mainly by
the well-heeled minority I'll read that
again sometimes these have to be a bit
worded uh bit wordy because we want to
keep them careful and at our debates by
the way both sides sign off on the
wording of the resolution again that's
going to be about electric vehicles in
October between now and 2035 electric
vehicles in the consumer Market will
likely disappoint environmentalists by
remaining a product bought mainly by the
well-heeled minority well I do hold in
my hand the soil Forum Tootsie Roll
which will go to the winner according to
Oxford style voting of this debate uh
drum roll please
um the yeps yeah
well um the yes vote Rose from
45.7 to 58 percent so it picked up a
little over 12 points that's the number
to beat
the no vote went from 34.5 to 34.5 it
remained flat and therefore the Tootsie
Roll goes to the S vote congratulations
and please come
please come to our after party and meet
and greet The Debaters and uh and the
great uh uh our man who's going to do
Lou Perez who'll do book signing in
sales Uptown from here two blocks yeah